I'm Jonathan Brower and I'm a scout master with troop 19 in
Fort Wayne, Indiana.
This edition of the scout master podcast is sponsored by
backers like me.
And now the old scout master.
Are you familiar with Horace Keppar?
He's one of my favorite authors.
He wrote early in the last century about camping, and
quite an outdoorsman, and he had this to say. to be sure,
even though a man rigs up his own outfit, he never
gets it quite to suit him.
Every season sees the downfall of some cherished scheme, the
failure of some fond contrivance.
Every winter sees you again fussing over your kit,
altering this, substituting that and flogging your
wits with the same old problem of how to save weight
and bulk without the sacrifice of utility.
All thoroughbred campers do this regularly as the
birds come back in spring, and their kind has been
doing it since the world began.
It's good for us.
If some misguided genius should invent a camping
equipment that nobody could find fault with, half our
pleasure in life would be swept away.
Oh, we do love our gear, don't we?
And you know that hasn't changed.
It hasn't changed since the early part of the last
century at least, when Horace Keppart wrote this.
That comes to mind because it's part of a PDF
that I have to offer at ScoutMasterCGcom, called
Going Camping, Go Light.
I'll have a link to it in the post that contains
this podcast,
And this happens to be podcast number 268..
Welcome back to the ScoutMaster podcast.
This is Clark Green
Looking in the mailbag. we heard this week from
John Moore, who is the committee chair of PAC and
Troop 130 in Geneva, Switzerland.
John wrote to say I'd like to request using
some things I found on your blog for a new
parent session with our graduating Weeblos parents.
There are some things that I find useful and I
couldn't have said better.
I hope you won't mind if I extract some of your
points to share with the parents.
I'm glad I found your blog.
Thank you for sharing your experience with the
world. Well, John, thank you for your kind words.
I'm glad you're finding what we've produced
useful and, naturally,
Please feel free to use anything I've created
to advance the greater cause of scouting.
All I ask is that you let people know where you
found it, And that goes for you too
And anything that I've come up with. if you want
to use it, you don't need to ask my permission.
Just go ahead, and all I ask is that you let
people know where you found it.
There you go.
Hey, you're going to love this email.
This is. this is really great.
And this is from a reader and listener, Robert
Williams, who's a new Scout Master,
And he said: we just had our first real patrol
leaders council meeting in a long time.
It was fantastic.
I followed your advice as closely as possible,
although I probably should have been a bit
stricter in living how much I talk.
Well, Robert, everybody's got to deal with that.
I can talk the horns off a billy goat and
the feet off an iron pot,
So I understand what you're dealing with.
But anyway, Robert goes on to say: before
the meeting started, I distributed the patrol
leader and senior patrol leader handbooks
I had just purchased.
I sat down and said: OK, so what do you
all think we should do?
What's a patrol leaders council for?
The senior patrol leader said I'll bet
it's in the books and started flipping
through the pages.
He found the agenda in the senior patrol
leaders handbook and just started
working his way through it.
He got to the part about patrol reports
and he said: OK, we'll go around and turn.
Here's what I want you to tell me.
At that point I excuse myself to get
up and get a cup of hot chocolate.
I came back a couple of minutes later
and the patrol reports were going well.
One of the patrol leaders brought up a
behavioral issue and they discussed
that. and the senior patrol leaders said:
well, have you talked to him?
Have you talked it over with the other
scouts? If it keeps happening, come to
me and if we need to, we'll go to Mr
Williams. At the beginning of their
meeting they were looking at me a lot,
asking me questions and looking for my
approval. So I did a lot of real,
exaggerated things like looking
blankly for a few seconds and then
saying melodramatically:
Oh did you mean me?
What were you talking to me for?
And I looked behind me, feigning
confusion once in a while, seeing
if I could figure out who they were
talking to.
Finally, I had the assistant senior
patrol leader read the paragraph where
it says the scout master is only
there for advice and guidance.
And by the end of the meeting they
were mostly speaking to each other in:
the senior patrol leader, not me.
When the senior patrol leader got to
the big event planning section on the
agenda, he started dividing up the
jobs amongst the patrols and we're
having a first year orientation
camp out soon
Now. historically that camp
out's mostly been planned by adults,
So I was excited to see the senior
patrol leader go ahead and plan
it and divide the responsibilities
amongst patrols.
I probably did a little too much
talking here, asking some questions
and making a few suggestions,
But the patrol leaders council was
making all the decisions.
Then they got to the part where
they're supposed to plan for the
next few troop meetings.
They did get a little off track
and I had to redirect them a
little. but they realized they
should use those meetings to get
ready for the camp out and they
started deciding what to do each
week.
So they planned out those next
two weeks and it was a beautiful
thing to see.
I was just blown away watching
these young men take charge and
make plans.
I really didn't think it was
going to work.
The senior patrol leader always
seemed so uncertain of himself.
But now I see if you just give
them the room and set some
expectations, they'll work to
achieve that.
If you elbow them out of the way
and just do it for them, they'll
sit quietly and let you take
over.
This patrol leaders council
meeting ran about 45 minutes
and honestly I wish they'd had
more time because I was so
interested in what they had to
discuss.
I only had to provide a few
nudges here and there.
I may have overdone it on
praising them, because at one
point they asked if I was being
sarcastic, but I was actually
very sincere.
It went 10 times better than I
expected and I told them. so
They expressed mock offense that
I had such low expectations of
them.
Thanks for all your help.
This is a very promising start
and I'm very excited. so far,
so good.
Well, Robert, that's a fantastic
report and I'll repeat exactly
what Robert said.
Now I see that if you just
give them room and set some
expectations, they'll work to
achieve that.
But if you elbow them out of
the way and just do it for them,
they'll sit quietly and let you
take over.
Couldn't have said it better
myself. Robert,
That's a great report and I
expect to keep hearing great
things about how this is
working out for you.
Hey, over on the blog this week.
Oh boy, we got a lot of
attention with this post titled
Stop Being a Merit Badge
Counselor.
Lots of comments and a big
discussion about several things
to do with merit badges
Once that was posted this past
week. go over to
scoutmastercgcom
and read the post, but make
sure you read the comments
to very interesting discussion.
I also posted my first
impressions of a new tent
that I have to review, the
Teton Mountain Ultra 3..
Looks very, very promising.
Looks like a great choice at
a good price for scouts.
Once again over on
scoutmastercgcom.
Let's see we had two or three
great live chats this week.
Keep an eye on my Facebook and
Twitter feeds about the live
chats.
They're mostly on weekday
mornings and a lot of people
stop through and sign in and
we chat for a bit.
And in addition to all of those
frequent fliers who normally
stop by, we chatted with
John Clements, who's from troop
692 in Castlebury, Florida.
Greg Brennam is a scout who's
a scoutmaster for troop 901
in Cypress, Texas.
Peter, who is an assistant
scoutmaster for troop 110 in
Millbury Massachusetts.
Monica, who is a troop
committee person.
Wendy, who is an assistant
scoutmaster in Illinois,
And Jeremy Jenkins, who's a
scoutmaster in China Grove,
North Carolina, with troop 315,
and Michael Cotter from
Columbus, Ohio, where he's a
den leader with PAC 41 and a
group scoutmaster with the
97th Lucas Sullivan scout
group, which is a group with
the Baden Powell Service
Association.
So before we go any further,
everything at scoutmastercgcom
is there to help you as a
scouter,
And I hear from people all
over the world who tell me
that it helps
And that's very, very
gratifying.
So to keep everything freely
available, I depend on people
just like you who become
backers.
Now it's an unusual idea,
So let me take a moment to
explain. If I was sending you
a paper magazine or a newsletter,
you'd expect there to be some
costs associated with that.
I need to pay printers and
authors and I need to pay
postage.
What happens these days is in
the digital world is pretty
similar to that newsletter,
because somebody has to
spend their time producing
the content and then incur the
expenses of publishing it,
And that's what I do.
And backers are the folks who
make a one time kind of
voluntary subscription payment,
and that money covers the
expenses of producing and
publishing what you find on
scoutmastercgcom, including
the podcast that you're
listening to right now.
So here's what I need you to
do: Go to scoutmastercgcom
sometime this week,
Click the support link at the
top of the page and you'll
find a number of options
That will make you a
scoutmastercgcom backer.
And I want to take a moment to
personally thank David
Goldenberg and Carson Boone,
who both have become backers
since the last podcast.
Once again go to
scoutmastercgcom, click the
support link at the top of the
page and become a backer this
week
And I'll thank you during my
next podcast.
Well, in this podcast I have
some email questions to answer,
But before I do that, in
scoutmaster ship in seven
minutes or less, we're going to
talk about who signs off rank
requirements and that'll take up
the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall
we scout master ship in seven
minutes or less?
I wanted to take a minute just
to cover this, because you'll
see in the email segment next
that I got a question about
patrol leaders signing off rank
requirements,
And I can't really remember a
time where patrol leaders in our
troop did not sign off rank
requirements.
So I'm always a little surprised
when people find this
unusual.
So I guess what I understand,
that this is not like
necessarily a common practice
in all troops.
So when we have a question
about something like this, what
do we want to do?
Well, you know you can
listen to me talk and talk and
talk, and I can give you ideas
and I can give you opinions.
You don't want to go on ideas
and opinions alone, do you?
You want to go to the resources
that are provided to you by your
scouting organization and make
sure that you're getting things
right.
It takes a little study,
It takes a little work to do
that
And I do my best to remind
everybody- don't take my word
for it.
Go to your resources. make
sure you're doing your best
to deliver scouting to the
young people in your community.
Now about this question about
who signs off on rank
requirements.
Well, if you're involved
with the BSA, here's the
resources that help answer
that question.
The first is in the Guide to
Advancement 2015..
I'll have a link to it in the
post that contains this
podcast,
And when we talk about the
Guide to Advancement, we talk
about long numbers, right,
So get your pencils ready.
This is in section 4.2.1.2,
titled A Scout Is Tested
And, quoting from that section,
the unit leader authorizes
those who may test and pass
the scout on rank requirements.
They might include his patrol
leader, senior patrol leader,
an assistant unit leader,
another scout or the unit
leader himself.
Merit Badge counselors teach
and test on requirements for
merit badges.
Once a scout has been tested
and signed off by someone
approved to do so,
the requirement has been met.
The unit leader is accountable
for ensuring proper
advancement procedures are
followed.
A part of this responsibility
includes the careful selection
and training of those who
approve advancement.
So let's look at this for a
moment.
The unit leader- so in a scout
troop that would be the
scout master- authorizes
those who may test and pass
the scout on rank
requirements.
So who could that be?
OK, well, it could be the
unit leader or the scout
master himself,
It could be an assistant unit
leader,
It could be another scout,
It could be the scouts patrol
leader or senior patrol leader.
So it's pretty wide open
policy wise.
You don't want to go to your
troop meeting tomorrow night
and say, OK, patrol leaders
can sign off all rank
requirements.
That probably wouldn't be such
a great idea because
of what it says in the guide.
the unit leader is accountable
for ensuring proper advancement
procedures are followed,
and a part of this responsibility
includes the careful selection
and training of those who
approve advancement.
So you know you can't just
make a blanket statement and
say, well, all patrol leaders
can sign off all rank
requirements now, because that
wouldn't be really very
responsible, would it?
You would want to make sure
that your patrol leaders are
trained in proper
advancement procedures, right?
So anybody signing off
requirements really should
understand how to do it.
They should be trained.
Nobody should be signing off
requirements without first
having discussed this
with the unit leader. correct?
Once a scout's been tested
and signed off by somebody
approved to do so,
the requirement's been met.
He's not getting tested on it again.
So it's a pretty important moment.
Now I will tell you from my
experience: training patrol
leaders to do this very, very
simple, training adults to do it-
reasonably simple- and the
ongoing process, of course,
of them signing off requirements
and then and then, through
Scoutmaster conferences and
discussions with Scouts,
understanding how the requirements
were signed off- and it's not
that you have to retest the
requirements, You just might
ask a couple of questions about
them- Is a great opportunity
for a unit leader or a
Scoutmaster to mentor and
train his youth leadership.
It's a really great
opportunity.
So let's go to the Scoutmaster
handbook. very simple
statement there.
So this is in the Scoutmaster
handbook. in the advancement
section
It says step two: a scout
is tested and it says
this quote: Scouts might be
tested by adult troop leaders
or by their own patrol leaders,
troop guides or another junior
leader, provided that the youth
leader has already earned
the rank the scout is aiming
for. So we get a little
additional information in the
Scoutmaster handbook that
coincides with what we read
in the guide to advancement,
and the Scoutmaster handbook
adds this consideration:
provided that the boy leader
has already earned the rank
the scout is aiming for,
I think that's a very reasonable
provision. So, based on
that guidance from the resources
that we have, I'll tell you how
this works. in my own troop
Any youth leader is trained
and qualified to sign off
rank advancements as long as
he's earned that rank.
And you know it works very,
very well. And there are some
perennial objections to doing
that because it's felt that
youth won't be rigorous enough
in their examination of Scouts
for requirements and things.
Well, I really haven't found
that to be the case.
That happens sometimes, to be
sure, And when it does-
and we find out that it's
happened that you know the
requirement well, they kind of
rushed through that one.
Well, that's a great
opportunity to sit down with
whoever approved their
requirement and refine their
technique a little bit,
And then, if they really gave
short shrift to the Scout,
we have a discussion about
how they can fix that.
They're not going to go back
and retest the requirement,
but they're going to involve the
Scout in making sure that they
demonstrate their understanding
of that requirement, a situation
where they're sharing it with
other Scouts, which is also
recommended in the Guide to
Advancement.
So just a quick overview of
those things And, once again,
don't ever take my word for it.
Go to the, go to the resources
yourself,
Read what has to be said there
And if you find that I've got
something wrong or you think
I've got something wrong, make
sure to get in touch with me.
I always appreciate hearing about
that
Email. that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of
your emails.
So we've got two or three email
questions to answer this week.
The first one comes from Tim
Smith, who's the Scout Master of
Troop 52 in Danbury, Connecticut,
And Tim said this: I'd like to
start off by saying thanks for
both the blog and the podcast,
as well as the books.
They've given me some direction
as Scout Master and to our
Petroleum Council in changing
the way our troop has- quote-
always done things unquote.
Well, Tim, that's a challenge for
all of us. I can tell you
Troop 52 has 57 scouts
as of this writing.
The Petroleum Council, which we
still call the green bar, meets
monthly and typically for a few
minutes after each troop meeting.
They also meet in the late
spring to plan for the coming
year. Currently, our patrols
do not meet outside of troop
meetings. So I have two or
three questions for you.
Number one is you mentioned
in the description of a ideal
quote, unquote- troop meeting
in one of your podcasts that
patrol leaders would be signing
off requirements for younger
scouts. Currently, our Scout
Master, Assistant Scout Masters
and Junior Assistant Scout Masters
are the only ones authorized
to sign rank requirements,
But I've been considering
extending this to patrol leaders.
Has this always been the case
in your troop And, if not,
what was the transition? like,
Tim, inspired by your email
question I shared earlier in
Scout Mastership in seven minutes
or less about the mechanics of
this question, I can't honestly
remember a time where patrol
leaders didn't sign off
requirements of my troops, so I
really can't comment on a
transition. I don't really
imagine there needs to be like a
big giant transition-y thing at
all. I think that the scouts
will get it immediately. Make sure
to follow the resources, make sure
patrol leaders understand the
responsibility involved and I
think you'll find that it works
just fine, Tim. second question:
was we limit terms and
positions of responsibility to
one year? Scouts are limited to
a single year term as the senior
patrol leader. Do you think we
ought to have this kind of
limitation, Or should we just
let things roll? We've also
limited these positions to
scouts who have at least first
class rank, so that they have
a position of responsibility to
satisfy advancement requirements
for higher ranks. Should the
senior patrol leader only
appoint those scouts that come
to him or all that need a
position? Well, Tim, as to the
length of terms and
qualifications for positions of
responsibility, first let's
talk about the length of the
term. Oddly enough, I've found
that the length of the term has
very little effect on the way
leadership develops or the
level of competence that they
ultimately reach. Any period
of time that somebody's going
to be in a position of
responsibility is divided into
thirds. The first third is
getting to know the job, the
second third is getting good
at it and the third third is
being good at the job. So
whether the tenure in that
position is a week long or
three years long, I think that
those thirds they'll fill up
any length of tenure. I've had
guys who are crew chiefs for
our week long trips in
Canada and their development in
those steps, in those three
steps, is almost identical to
the way a senior patrol
leader develops over a six
month period, which happens to
be the length of the term
that we have in our troop.
Prior to that, we had senior
patrol leaders serving for a
full year Roughly. they
would develop in thirds. I
don't know that the length of
the tenure is really all that
important, other than in
that it is long enough to
fulfill rank requirements.
Personally, I pay very little
attention to the qualifications
or rank requirements in
positions of responsibility. I
have very little to say about
positions of responsibility to
begin with, but I find that
if a scout wants to advance,
he'll find a position of
responsibility. I can't recall
one of our scouts being held
back because he lacked the
opportunity to occupy a
position of responsibility.
And, like I said, who ends up
in those positions has very
little to do with me And
I'm not really all that
concerned with who gets
elected or appointed to
those positions. They're all
youth decisions. I just work
with whoever they choose. Now
I will advise the senior
patrol leader if he asks.
when it comes down to
appointing guys to positions
of responsibility, Some senior
patrol leaders ask me and
some don't. So Tim's third
question was: you've also
mentioned that you have one
meeting night a month
dedicated to boards of review
and the patrol leaders
council meeting. If I
understand you correctly, you
have another night dedicated
to patrol meetings. How
smoothly did the
transition to that schedule
go? How did the scouts
handle it, And do they find
that it distracts from
the presentation of the
program? Well, I've talked
about this before, but let
me tell you what our- what
our- meeting night schedule
is. We have usually one
or two troop meetings
every month, one or two
patrol meetings every
month and the Monday
night That's when we
meet. We meet on Monday
nights after we go
camping. each month is
dedicated to the
patrol leaders council
meeting, scout master
conferences, boards of
review. It's not a
regular troop meeting. Now,
I don't know that there's
any real problem with
the program being
presented because of that
schedule. It seems to run
fine, so far as I can
tell. Sometimes we have
four meetings a month,
sometimes three, sometimes
five, depending on
the calendar, But that's
basically the way they
divide up, which
exchanged one or two
of our troop meetings
each month for patrol
meetings, because we
wanted to encourage
patrols to meet and do
things together And we
found that trying to do
that outside of that
one night a week was
a real scheduling
challenge for them. So
we decided we don't
need to have a troop
meeting every single time
we get together. So we
opened it up so the patrol
leaders could plan
independently their own
activities and what
they're going to do that
night. And our scouts
have received it
reasonably well and it
seems to work pretty
good for us. Heard from
Rob Karagnan who is
with Scout Troop 1
in Portland, Maine, And
he said: can you help
clarify the BSA policy
on stoves? I am
interested in getting
an alcohol burning
stove But I've heard
and read that the BSA
has banned alcohol stoves.
I did look at policy
on storage, handling
and use of chemical fuels
and equipment And you'll
find that in the Guide
to Safe Scouting and I'll
have a link to that in the
post that contains this
podcast. Rob says: this
policy tells me I can
only use commercial stoves
and use them only within
the manufacturer's
instructions. Is that the
way that you read this
in the Guide to Safe
Scouting? Well, yeah,
Rob, that's exactly the way
I read it. The whole
alcohol stove ban is one
of those urban legends
in scouting that seem to
persist because I don't
think too many people
have bothered to read
the actual policy, So
they assume that all alcohol
stoves are banned. If you
read the policy, it is
just what it says: Homemade
alcohol stoves are
prohibited, but
commercially manufactured
stoves they're OK. And
then there's a statement
about fuel, And this
is also pretty clear:
Use the fuel specified by
the manufacturer. Pretty
simple, right. So if you
get a commercially made
alcohol stove and you use
it according to the
manufacturer's instructions
and you use only the fuel
that the manufacturer
specifies, we're in good
shape. Now the only thing
that I would add, Rob, is
understand that alcohol burns
with a very visible flame
in daylight. So make sure
you read the directions
that come with your stove,
because a common accident
that happens with alcohol
stoves is when somebody
tries to refuel the stove
while it's still burning
or the burner is hot. So
make sure that it's out
and the burner is cool
to the touch before you
refuel the stove. Once again,
folks go to the guide
to save scouting. read
that policy and see if
I've got it right. And
the last email for this
week is this question: What
is the maximum recommended
weight for backpacks? Some
of the old
scouters in the troop
keep telling me that one
third body weight is
the maximum, And I find
references online telling me
one quarter body weight
is maximum and I'd appreciate
your wisdom on this. Well,
I got to tell you the
percentage of body weight is
not a very good measure
when it comes to figuring
out what the maximum
weight of a backpack
ought to be, If you think
about this. so one third
or one quarter body weight
means 150 pound person
could carry up to 50 pounds
And to me that's
way way too heavy. It's
much more than it needs to be.
My pack usually weighs
in around 25 to 35 pounds
And 35 pounds is pretty heavy
for for a two night weekend.
If I was a lot more serious
about it, I paid more attention
to it, I could trim about
five pounds off of the
weight that I carry, But
I'm reasonably happy
getting it to in that
30 pound area. Scouts
in my experience are all
over the map with what
they're able to carry
comfortably. 30 pounds
is not necessarily too much
for a small, framed younger scout.
Now some smaller scouts
are going to be really taxed
trying to carry that much
And I've had much bigger
and more and older scouts
who have real difficulty
carrying a backpack.
It just seems to get under
their skin and it's very,
very difficult for them to do
And this is why, when we go
backpacking, we go
backpacking by patrols.
You know the whole troop is
there, but the patrols
sticks together.
They share their food,
They share their cooking gear,
stoves, tents, and the guys
who are more capable of
carrying more weight will
usually be very happy
to do that if somebody
is having trouble in their patrol.
So I know there's a lot
of advice out there that
talks about a percentage
of body weight as being
a measure for the maximum,
But, like I said, there are
so many different situations
and so many different types
of scouts that I would not
use that as a rule of thumb.
The way that it works best
for us has been to stay
in that 25 to 35 pound area
and to make sure that
everybody sticks together
as patrol,
And it usually seems
to work out just fine that way.
If you have a question for me,
it's very easy to get in touch
and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this
268th edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
Go to the blog at
scoutmastercgcom
and you can sign up
to an email subscription
that will send every update
to the blog to your email inbox.
You can join the other
mobile scouts
or have the Scoutmaster
CG app on their mobile devices,
and the app is available
both on the Google Play
and the iTunes app store.
You can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
There's 8,900 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook.
There's 1,200
tweeters that tweet along
with us on Twitter.
There are 2,000 pinners
who pin the
Pultritudinous pictures
we proper publicly.
on Pinterest,
You can watch Scoutmaster
CG on YouTube
and you can join
the 500 odd folks
who form the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG circle
on Google+.
What's that you say
You can't face Facebook?
Twitter makes you better.
You've no interest in Pinterest.
You don't put the? U in YouTube
and you're a minus
when it comes to Google+.
That's okay, Bunky.
Just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email.
Yep, you can email me.
Clark Green,
your comments and questions
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E.
at scoutmastercgcom,
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
do not have the sponsorship
or endorsement
of any scouting organization.
They are solely a product
of my own ramblings
and prognostications.
It's just me talking
into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand
to scouters everywhere
and have a little bit of fun
along the way,
And speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.